مع الزلزال اللي شاغل الدنيا كلها
والتوقعات الماليه المنصات الاخبار عن
زلازل القادمه كمان في صور متداوله في مصر
عامله حالها كبيره من الرعب والقلق والخوف
وهي الصور اللي شايفينها امامكم مشاهدينا
لهذا الهبوط الارضي بمنطقه السلوم على
كورنيش الاسكندريه بعمق عده امتار وطول
عشرات الامطار
الناس بس شافت منظر هبوط الارض خافت
وانرعبت وكثار منهم فورا ربطوا الموضوع
بالزلزال اللي فات وتوقعات الزلازل اللي
جايه وقالوا هذا يا اما من توابع زلزال
سوريا وتركيا يا اما صاير زلزال في مصر او
في زلزال جاي وهذا انذار وتحضير له خاصه
وانه هذا مو اولا انهيار ومن اسبوع بالضبط
وفي نفس يوم زلزال سوريا وتركيا الكبير
كورنيش الاسكندريه كان واوصار في تشققات
طوليه صوروها الناس ونشروا مقاطع منها
كمان وهذه امتدت عشرين كيلو متر والناس
وقتها قالوا برضو هادي من الهزات
الارتداديه تشقق الاسبوع الماضي مع انهيار
اليوم خلوا الخوف والرعب يسيطر على منصات
مصر
وزاره الري والموارد المائيه ردت على خوف
الناس وحبه تطمنهم مؤكدت بكل الطرق
والوسائل انه الموضوع له زلزال ولا له
علاقه بالزلازل لكن تفسيرات الوزاره تعددت
يعني في بيان صحفي للوزاره قال انه سبب
الهبوط الارضي هو الامواج العاتيه
المصاحبه لنوه الكرم وانه تم اصلاح الهبوط
والتعامل معه نموه الكرم هي ظاهره مناخيه
بترتبط بشده الرياح ووزاره الامطار وبتكون
خلال مده زمنيه محدده اذا كان بيان
الوزاره لكن المتحدث باسم الوزاره كان
تفسيره مختلف وعبر برنامج الحكايه مع
الزميل عمرو اديب قال انه السبب هو تدفق
مياه الامطار وما يلو اي علاقه بالامواج
والموضوع يعني طبقا لمعاينه اللجنه ناتج
عن وجود كميات كبيره من الامطار في
المنطقه الامطار دي تتفقد بشكل كبير واثرت
على البلاطات بتاعه الكورنيش في المنطقه
دي اللي ظهرت
يعني حضرتك في الصور ده تاثير ناتج عن
تدفق كميات كبيره من مياه الامطار يعني
الموضوع مالوش علاقه
بالامواج او المنطقه الشاطئيه في حد ذاتها
او تاثير الامواج في المنطقه دي ولكن
التاثير في معظمه ناتج عن تدفق كميات
كبيره من الامطار على المنطقه دي
عموما سواء الموضوع من الامواج او من
الامطار او من الهواء في ناس كثير اطمنت
ان المهم الموضوع مو زلزال ولا له علاقه
فيه بس ترى لكن للامانه في ناس تانيه مو
مصدقه ولسه بتشكك